Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. episode. With Dr. Marianne Trent Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast.
I am Dr. Marianne Trent and I'm a qualified clinical psychologist. I'm a qualified clinical psychologist with a fractured elbow, which was not on the plan, wasn't on the agenda and so this episode is going to be a little bit shorter as yet it's thrown my life slightly into chaos. So I hope you'll find this quick overview useful about how you go about becoming a clinical psychologist in the UK. That is if you are a UK resident. I will aim to do future content for how you do conversions in future. If that is of interest to you, you could listen to an episode I did with Michaela Thomas which is episode 61 of the aspiring psychologist podcast so I hope you'll find this really useful we have of course got
compassionate Q&A's you can catch up on and the next one is coming to you on the 2nd of May watch out on my socials for those and And yeah, all of the replays are easily available from my YouTube, Dr. Marianne Trent. And if you're watching on YouTube now, please do subscribe and like. Hope you find this useful. If you've got any ideas for future podcast episodes, then please do let me know. So whilst I'm waiting for people to join us, I thought I would briefly go through A, who I am, and B, what the process is for becoming a clinical psychologist in the UK. If you're watching on YouTube, why not subscribe? That would be good good i will briefly go through what the process is to become a clinical psychologist in the uk um so it is a three-year professional doctorate qualification the majority
of places are nhs funded at band six level but it is also possible on some courses I think there's maybe three four maybe five courses that accept self funding but that's not done without due consideration because you'd need to pay the expenses which I think are about 30 grand a year I think and you'd need to also pay your own living expenses to be able to afford food rent fuel all of, all of those things. So it's not a small amount of money. Sometimes people's employers ask them to, well, they agree to fund it for them. So that also is a possibility if you're not feeling particularly flush. But even then, even if you want to self-fund,'s still incredibly you know competitive to get a place and they're not going to let you get onto that doctorate if you haven't got the appropriate
skills qualifications and expertise so by the time you have an interview for the doctorate in clinical psychology whether that is self-funded or whether that is taught you will have an undergraduate degree which confers which offers you the graduate basis for registration with the British Psychological Society you may also see that called the GBC graduate basis for certification I think something like that but it changed a few years ago so you might see at GBC you might see at GBR and both is fine but yes that's not enough usually usually you may have done some additional qualifications you may have done a postgraduate certificate you may have done a master's not essential but always useful to evidence that you're able to strengthen
your academic experience. You are likely pretty much essentially going to have needed to have done some element of research or dissemination of your abilities, which highlights why you're going to be a brilliant clinical psychologist. And what else? Relevant experience. So I got on to training in 2008 and I graduated in 2002. And it wasn't all pedal to the metal. I did do a little bit of backpacking around the world for six months and I saved up to do that. So yeah, there was a fair amount of sitting in a hammock and drinking lovely cocktails. But there was also a lot of hard work across a variety of different clinical populations where I was able to hone my craft. So that is a little bit about the route.
Once you're on the doctorate in clinical psychology, you do that for three years. You have to pass a variety of clinical placements you usually have between five to six four to six clinical placements and you'll do assignments during that time and then you need to pass each clinical placement and you also have assignments and a piece of unique research to do which composes your thesis. It's a lot to balance. It's a lot to juggle. But if you were not aware of that, I hope that's useful. But if you found this helpful, please do consider leaving me a testimonial that I can use on socials or drop me something anonymously. That's great. Or on LinkedIn, you can write me a recommendation if we're not already connected on there I think you might need to send me a connection request too to demonstrate that you think what I've got
to say is useful and supportive like I said the podcast can be really useful especially the interviews episodes and the interview prep episodes so 65 is learn and learn and revise better 64 is preparing for interview success optimally prepare for interviews is um episode 10 so 10 64 and 65 there's also um other replays that you can watch um on my youtube channel dr marianne trent um and um yeah if you think you might find it helpful to come aboard to the aspiring psychologist membership there is no minimum um requirement for you to stay you want to just come for a month and see if it's a good fit for you that's absolutely okay too there'll be links in my bio for how you can do that um and like I said the uh the clinical psychologist
collective and the aspiring psychologist collective make excellent reads as well thank you so much for watching i hope you found that useful thank you also for being part of my world and trusting you to bring you what you need to know um when you need to know it and if you've got any questions or ideas for future episodes please do get in touch i will look forward to catching up with you for the next episode of the podcast, which is available to you from 6am on Mondays. By which time I hope my elbow will be a little bit more healed. Take care and thank you for being part of my world. Thank you. It's right here in this book. It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective.
It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective. If you're looking to become a psychologist Then let this be your guide With this podcast at your side You'll be on your way to being qualified It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast With Dr. Marianne Trent My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological wellbeing practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist.
It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me of confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself so if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay but trust me you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.